(dramatic orchestral music)
- Welcome to "Metta World News".
Our top story, why
are people always
trying to steal my magic?
In other news, cat
litter can be used
to blind people when fighting.
Interesting, I didn't know that.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday,
February biscuit fountain drink.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
In sports, I'd
rather eat my hand
than to have my penis cut off.
I'd really have to believe
someone was gonna cut it off.
But if I did, I can
definitely eat my hand.
I know because I had a
dream where I did it.
It was horrible, I
ate my whole hand.
Now that's what
you call rhetoric.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday
April hurricane slipknot.
I'm Metta World,
peace, good night.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
In fashion, if you woke up
and there was a four-inch
miniature human
standing on your chest,
would you swap them off?
I was really challenged
by this question.
I would hope that I'd
engage them in conversation,
but in reality, I think
I'd be scared of them
and swat them away, which
would probably kill them.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday
October noise canceling
the octagon tire.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
Does that fulfill
my contract, Satan?
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
Our top story, ninja costumes
don't come in size triple X,
which is discriminatory
against enormous assassins.
You know what?
Forget about the teleprompter.
I need to speak from the heart.
Well, that wraps up
"Metta World News"
for this Wednesday, May
staple gun hairbrush.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
I wish there was
a genie in here.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday
March hybrid ice rink.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
Hey Jen, where's that genie?
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
Our top story, the Pope
is thinking of moving
out the Vatican so feral
cats can live there.
Now let's go to Homemakers
Corner with Metta World Peace.
Thank you, Metta.
You need five
plastic grocery bags
to make an effective parachute.
Thanks, Metta.
And you will die
if you try that.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday
November morning
star cocktail napkin.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
Our top story, a professional
athlete should never post
online looking for people
to live action role play
"Hunger Games" with them.
I'm sorry, Gerard,
Kaylee and Zach.
Well that wraps up
"Metta World News"
for this Wednesday, August
microwave woodchuck.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Welcome to "Metta World News".
In science news,
it is impossible to knock
yourself out with your own fist.
Let's not fall behind America.
Well, that wraps up "Metta
World News" for this Wednesday
biscuit, biscuit, biscuit.
I'm Metta World,
peace, goodnight.
You win fish,
I'm the one in the aquarium.